so I'm guessing that you already have a
sense that saving money is a good idea
it's good for a rainy day that's why we
have an emergency fund there might be
unexpected Interruption to your income
or unexpected costs that happen from
your car breaking down or maybe medical
expenses or you might want to save for
something like retirement or down
payment on a house but the next question
is how do you actually go about saving
the money we all know it's sometimes a
little bit more fun to spend money than
to save money and what I do personally
well I do a few things first of all try
to set a budget and we talk about that
in depth in other videos think about
what your after tax income is every
month and then think about your needs
your wants and then how much you save
we've talked about the 50 30 20 rule
which is just a rule of thumb try to at
least save 20 of your money and the way
that you save 20 is spend no more than
50 on needs no more than 30 percent on
Watts now obviously if you can save more
than 20 percent of your money even
better but then how do you do that
one thing is set aside some money every
paycheck every could be every week every
other week it could be every month
that's just a little bit harder to
access maybe your money gets that from
your pay gets deposited into your
checking account either automatically or
you deposit a check well maybe every
month and there's ways that you can
automate this you make a transfer from
your checking account to your savings
account makes it a little bit harder for
that money to be accessed and you will
only access that money you tell yourself
self I will only access that money in an
actual rainy day the other thing to
remind yourself is a little bit every
day or every week or every month can add
up to a lot it might feel like hey if I
save only a hundred dollars this week
what's the big deal maybe I should just
spend it but remember if you save a
hundred dollars per week that's going to
amount to five thousand two hundred
dollars over the course of a year which
is going to amount to fifty two thousand
dollars over the the course of 10 years
and that's before we even think about
how you could invest it and even grow it
above and beyond that so even that
hundred dollars a week goes a long long
long way to building your wealth and
obviously protecting you and your family
from those rainy days from those
emergencies